thank you
[Music]
do you guys know about Christina
Phillips from Mississippi no no she um
sounds familiar you're one of the
world's fattest people she was on my 600
pound life remember that show that was
like yeah document she weighed like 700
something pounds did they had to break
down the wall to get her out with a
forklift no she didn't even leave her
house she she was so depressed from you
know like being that big she didn't
leave her house for two years did they
have to use a kiddie pool for a bathtub
they sound like just rephrase yo mama
jokes
they're like actual episodes really you
saw him too yeah I saw him did you see
that one where they where she ironed her
clothes in the driveway Joe
that's [__] up man no but the dad was
bathing
and this bowl didn't even use like a
regular humans like [__] soap they
using the shower this [__] had
Ajax like he had like fish soap oh [__]
and he was covering his son with the
dish soap and scrubbing him with that it
gets you really dried out though it is
an episode of that fat ass TV show the
exfoliation two fat sisters that a lot I
paid my bills my bills are paid you know
what I'm talking about which one the
with the two sisters that are arguing
with each other and they're like yeah
bills my bills are paid I remember that
I haven't seen that did you see one
where they wanna one went on a date but
the whole like family went for real yeah
that sounds cute why did the whole
family go I don't remember it was on the
I mean it was on a TV show so like the
one girl had a date and they all went
yeah moral support yeah so she couldn't
even walk to her room from the living
room couch it was like really bad
um 700 pounds this is her
machine Phillips right there yeah
I couldn't really I remember this girl
yeah yeah yeah she was like really uh I
won't say big but not in many ways but
people that could get that big I feel
like they're strong as [__] dude because
every time I just feel bloated I'm like
oh I'm gonna die and I'm like not even
that big imagine if you had a carry 600
pounds on your skeleton every year every
day that's a bit different moment right
there so she uh or I can't even hold 600
pounds yeah dude I probably can though
he's probably not the one that would
yeah I would like if all of us I think
he could carry the most weight but still
yeah he's been carrying the show around
for a long time
you guys are familiar with gastric
bypasses though right yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like a
surgery that helps you lose weight but
that's what big boy got too yeah yeah
that's basically stapling your stomach
though right yeah like
you can't at this heavy you can't get it
like you have to lose weight to get gas
oh wow they're so fat it can't get
bypass
no you have to like actually and a lot
of doctors
um won't do it until you commit to
having a habit of losing weight oh that
makes a lot of sense because just get it
back yeah yeah I don't like how you're
fat shaming her I love how I'm trying to
say oh she didn't do a gastric bypass
but Trisha Paytas uh got liposuction and
she was she vlogged all of this and like
the day of recovery she's eating hot
wings
amazing yeah she is a great I wonder if
that hurts
the liposuction no after you get that
surgery and you eat hot wings and it
burns going down that's probably tough
so she wanted to get that surgery the
doctor told her I will only do it on the
condition that you lose this much weight
she had to drop a ton of weight I don't
like those conditions that's fast
shaming
she's like you're too fat what are your
conditions Joe yeah because she's like
you're too fat she shouldn't be [__]
calling her too fat for anything because
being Fat's not unhealthy
she's right get it get him no no doctor
should ever tell anybody that the two
pencil [__] that [__] no especially as
an expert like what's he thinking so
here she is dare you say she's too fat
that's her at 700 pounds
um she did the work required to earn the
surgery wow that's awesome hold on Nick
sorry for sure because she looks really
young dude this will change everything
knowing how old she is she was um
okay isn't it easier she could turn her
life around man should do that when
you're younger because your metabolism
yeah how long did it take her
um 10 I think almost 10 years wow can we
get another picture of her I just want
to see a difference yeah she has a
blanket she's hiding in can we see what
she looks like as a can we see the
picture can we see what she looks like
as a baby anything else you guys want to
see her in is it in a Victorian costume
yeah can I see her in a green shirt can
I see what her parents look like I'd
like to see the whole family tree here
you go here's a nice little oh the
family bushes bushes
is that enough for your AI to
reconstruct other angles so now what's
the conclusion you come up with after
gathering on his data no I just um
the required weight loss to get the
surgery done to her I didn't see how
much she had to lose for the surgery I
think it was already like hundreds of
pounds wow but this is her today at 185.
that's amazing
these are my favorite
10 years because she actually built the
lifestyle happiness
and now look how good she looks she
looks just as healthy to me on both
sides I think I think she's spreading
fat phobic propaganda right now exactly
whoa that's what I'm saying wait I see
with my eyes say that again this is the
same reason why people are mad at lizzo
right yeah yeah wow because she was a
savior to some right she started eating
salad and got [__] pissed at her
that's awesome yeah 180 a buck 85 Buck
85 okay fine so she that's lost the
required weight then got the gastric
bypass she had already developed the
habits exactly yeah she was 600 700 she
lost like four people dude at least he
lost like four you know who loves this
misogynists that's true shut up
because all guys just want skinny ass
girls yeah and then she had to live in a
man's world so what if it was a guy that
did this oh well then guess what massage
he's awesome right yeah he'd be awesome
James Bond can [__] as many women as he
wants but if a girl does that it's
massage it's [__] her
but you still got your Swagger to this
why are you [__] up the attitude yeah
so she um and did say something
interesting she said she she has to have
therapy because uh yeah whenever the
scale goes up a little bit yeah
she she like won't eat for like two days
but she has PTSD from it yeah this isn't
like this extreme but I had sibo I don't
know if you guys ever heard of that but
uh it was it's small intestinal bacteria
overgrowth but anyway it was kind of
I don't there was years of my life where
I just kept gaining weight and I I was
eating less and less and less I was
eating like under 1200 calories a day at
one point and like exercising like two
hours a day and it which I just kept
gaining weight and I found that I was
like this is not normal I don't know how
this is happening like if people are
like oh yeah you're just getting older
but it was like you're like hey how
about you eat less calories uh or how
about you eat eat
um less than you burn huh yeah it was
like I would wake up looking six months
pregnant and it was like it was just
really hard like is that your
intestine's fermenting yeah it doesn't
break down the food yeah it's like your
your gut biome got thrown off and so
there's more bad bacteria than good
bacteria and they just keep taking over
and they just keep creating like gases
and they they feed on your food like the
sugar and stuff and they like just get
bigger and bigger so anyway and then the
stress was like making me gain weight
because I didn't know what's wrong and I
was like working a lot and trying to fit
in two hour workouts and like trying to
meal plan and I was just really
stressful so then I found out that I had
that and I I had for like a year it was
like eight months of like being on this
extremely strict diet of like it's not
just like dieting healthy it's like you
can't eat certain foods like I couldn't
eat certain vegetables like broccoli I
couldn't have garlic onion I couldn't
have cough or I had coffee but I
couldn't have um I couldn't have any
creamer in the coffee could have any
sugar no no alcohol or something yeah
yeah because they feed on the sugar and
then I had to take these supplements and
like there's two routes you can go but I
want the herbal route first and that
doesn't work you can go the antibiotic
route but um it's really expensive both
ways uh and I had to go to a
nutritionist and it took like eight
months of like really solid discipline
work and I got rid of it eventually and
then you have to reincorporate your diet
because if you stay on that diet then it
it'll just like come back with it
whenever you eat those other Foods you
have to kind of like slowly
reincorporate these foods and it was
terrifying because every time I felt
like a little bit of blow I'd be like
attack it's back and it's still now
today sometimes I'm like oh no I [__]
up something happened I'm terrified of
antibiotics I like really hope I never
get an affection again because that's
what's caused it all and antibiotics I
watched it yeah I had two uh I had two
viruses but I had a UTI and um uh a
tonsillitis back to back
that was I gave her both that's [__]
throw [__] and [__] banging yeah
yeah both of them I do like both that's
a bag and they don't tell you how to
like you're supposed to take probiotics
like after taking antibiotics or during
it so I didn't know it was just like
back-to-back antibiotics wiped out my
entire thing probably started because it
was around Christmas time probably
started eating candy and chocolate and
like bad for you stuff during that time
and that's what threw off everything
doctor told me to start washing my dick
and I said why don't you wash these nuts
and he said that's kind of what I'm
trying to get you to do and I was like
why don't you watch these [__] nuts
foreign
[Music]